what's your poker face like Jason all
right I have one I just shut off and I
look like I'm gonna punch you in the
face
oh really yeah that happened in the show
It's very effective yeah I did a show at
skank Fest my the Jason Ellis show lot
in front of a live audience and a
comedian a comedian that I really like
that I haven't met told a dude to come
up to the stage and say hey you guys
suck you're not funny
and uh and the guy came down and said it
and I was like
I'm not
I'm like I thought we were doing good
and then I'm I'm burying myself right
now and then the guy next to me Dan Soto
goes wait
that guy got told by Shane Gillis to say
that and I'm like wait Shane Gillis
thinks I suck oh that's way worse than a
random dude and they're all joking about
it saying hey don't worry we discovered
the culprit but people DM me after the
show came out they could tell like I
shut off and I was like
I I really like that guy and I thought
that the show was doing well I thought I
was like you know what pretty talented
but to know that I suck is pretty [ __ ]
up I I saw him the next day and went up
to him about it what'd he say he said I
was just joking and I was like well I
think you're really funny even if you
don't think I'm funny regardless sit
back down now wait I'm gonna give him a
hug he may know he made up for it he did
he did yeah Jane did that's how you make
up
he said come on man I don't think you're
not funny at all like he if it's a bit
that it's right if that happened to you
you would shut down I know you Bobby I
did crying I know you I left the venue
and there were people like man Alice
what a show and I was like thank you oh
and I walked all the way back to my
hotel like shut off my wife when I go
back to the room like what I'm like it
doesn't matter just someone oh Jason
I've been there I've been there I've
been there I've been there don't worry
about it it's like the [ __ ] that guy
yeah and I noticed that the other guys
didn't get touched by it and I was like
you're touchy
[Laughter]
everybody else on stage was like Hey you
know Gillis and yeah right on I was like
still like how do I is it me that sucked
which part did I do that oh my God
better myself oh I love a good downward
spiral yes it's funny it's all in here
with us right this is we we
assume things and our minds go out of
control and all of a sudden it's a
whirlwind and you're out you're [ __ ]
yeah you know I mean so I'm sorry I got
booed off a stage in front of 20 000
people like 20 years ago something's
thrown it no things throw twenty
thousand people throwing
had his bottles at me I just like you
know how like a single team not funny
it's not a single tear came down my face
like this
and I just walked off stage didn't you
say bye you got to say bye I remember
seeing a replay and I was on stage going
I was so I was bombing so hard I started
mumbling on stage I started going down
and I couldn't even get a word out but
damn you just left and I just left the
stage but check it check it out bro they
still [ __ ] paid me dog what's up
that's not a very good thing that's a
terrible
yeah that was not there was a little bit
better ending
after and you crushed it no they I got
paid oh what's up I'd say yeah he's
right that's no the next night I did the
same show but I rearranged the lineup
and then I killed wait the lineup tell
me the jokes in a different lineup and
no it's the lady I followed I couldn't
follow her
who's Leslie Jones wait
wait
funny
is very funny
oh so yeah don't go out afterwards okay
I'm just starting to get into it yeah
learning stand up you mean yeah yeah
yeah it's the most nervous thing I've
ever done in my life and I fight like I
farted uh like 300 pound man on steroids
once and I was more nervous the other
day going out uh in front of 500 people
then anywhere near the bit right when
[ __ ] what I could tell Shane Khan was
like I'm Gonna Knock You Out And I was
like oh this is terrifying
it's more scared when I they said you're
gonna love this guy I was like I
probably won't I mean [ __ ] but Jake can
you listen can you think of it in this
way you're on stage right and you have
guys like was it Sam Morel or Mark
Norman would you say it was there the
comments at the comic the comics that
were there it was Shane oh no oh yeah no
Shane and uh uh Dan Soto Dan Soto so
just those three alone right guys just
those three alone they're the best
comics on planet Earth they are heavy
and you are with them
right you're in the same group with them
that's why so what does that say about
you
you're you belong there you should have
been it's not a fluke I needed somebody
to say that because I was like yeah
those are all Heavy Hitters which means
when he says this show isn't funny it's
me no I'm making it
that's what I thought he has done our
podcast before he's banned
fan now
now
right now wait a minute somebody did not
like me you can't bully my friend my
little sensitive Australian friend over
here wow right [ __ ] ban him write
that down write it down my bad dude wow
yeah Off With His Head this is
the biggest thing that's ever happened
yeah bro I have power dude